I’ve heard that type A personalities are
intense and type B personalities are more
chill.
But I’m really intense about my chilling.
WHAT AM I???
Hey A’s and B’s, Julian here for DNews.
I remember a time before the Myers-Briggs
Type Indicator was all the rage when people
neatly classified themselves in two categories.
You were either type A or type B.
Traditionally, type A’s are competitive,
driven, hard workers.
They are bossy, impatient, eat fast, and interrupt
people.
Type B’s are the opposite.
They’re more relaxed, living for the moment,
and apparently slow eaters.
In other words, type A’s are there to win,
while type B’s are just happy to be out
there.
The two personality types were defined in
the ‘50s by doctors Meyer Friedman and Ray
Rosenman, but they weren’t psychologists,
they were cardiologists.
So what, you may be wondering, were a couple
of heart doctors doing defining personality
types?
Well when they were conducting their research,
they were exploring if certain personality
traits increased someone’s risk of heart
disease.
For eight and a half years they followed over
3000 middle aged men, who were divided almost
evenly into the two personality types based
on a questionnaire they answered.
Their results, published in 1976, found that
type A people were almost twice as likely
to develop coronary heart disease than type
B people.
The finding isn’t without its controversies
though.
Aside from the fact that precisely zero women
participated, the motives behind this study
have been called into question.
In 2012 the American Journal of Public Health
published a paper by Dr. Mark Petticrew and
others of the London School of Hygiene and
Tropical Medicine.
In it Petticrew claims that after analyzing
documents from the tobacco industry, they
concluded that research on the type A behavior
pattern were funded by tobacco companies in
an effort to confound the link between smoking
and heart disease.
And a 2001 meta-analysis by Michael Myrtek
published in the International Journal of
Cardiology found that while hostility does
seem to have an association with coronary
heart disease, the effect size is so small
it’s not significant for prediction or prevention.
In other words, just being irritable and combative
is not enough to be a major risk factor for
a heart attack.
Of course if you fit the Type A personality
scheme and you turn to smoking to cope with
the stress, that’s bad news for your heart.
Actually, even without the stress, smoking
is bad, m’kay?
And it should be added that you probably don’t
fit neatly into either type A’s or type
B’s little boxes.
There are more than two types of people in
the world, it’s ok to #breakthrerules.
Maybe sometimes you’re intense about your
play.
The new Toyota Tacoma encourages you to break
the rules, and PLAY NOW.
After a ten-year wait, the all-new Tacoma
is finally here.
It’s been fully redesigned to play whenever
and wherever you want.
People love to define their personalities.
There are a plethora of free tests online
available and right now the Myers-Briggs Type
Indicator is so widespread that it’s used
by most fortune 100 companies when they’re
hiring people.
But it’s not based in science.
For a better personality breakdown, you need
the Big 5, and Laci explains what those are
here.
So here’s a fun little experiment we can
do.
I hypothesize that people who identify as
type A personalities, due to their eager and
competitive traits, are more likely to reply
to this video now that I’ve called them
out.
Let us know if you think you’re an A or
B in the comments, subscribe for more, and
I’ll see you next time on DNews.